[Music]
edan your first season on the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills are you
ready for this ride you know I wouldn't
be here if I wasn't
she could be struggling don't criticize
that what's your entry point to the
group who did you know I don't actually
bring into the group it looks like I
bringing it eating into the group
I actually don't I just happen to live
very close to where her Pilates studio
is so let's be at least honest shall we
you become friends with everyone or do
you make enemies in the group
I've never had an enemy in my entire
life whoa visage yourself into something
that's not your business there's a lot
going on inside of her and she's a
recovering alcoholic and so is him so
there's an interesting weave of the
storyline there - wolf Dee but I'm a
little bit in the drama this year with
the Kim and Eden and Lisa Rinna so I
never said anything about your husband's
let's do the story here are you kidding
me let's talk about your arrest well
what can you always expect from me I
will bring it always I always bring it I
really didn't expect it to go down the
road it went I wasn't expecting the
drama again the way it did but you know
it's the Kim and Lisa you know what what
can I say you know it happened Lisa
Rinna honestly I don't think we'll ever
be the same after Amsterdam and they try
to do the right thing and be civil and
all that but it just doesn't seem to go
ever and I I think at some point you
kind of gotta say we're just not gonna
never get along and see you later
Reena needs to sober you lip shot so
letter heavy stepping on this things in
you know these deep-seated issues and
but everything turns out okay in the end
we'll see